the way you set up your training general
development sets and test sets can have
a huge impact on how rapidly you or your
team can make progress on building
machine learning application let's see
in team even teams and very large
companies set up these data sets in ways
that really slowed down rather than
speeds up the progress of the team let's
take a look at how you can set up these
data sets to maximize Eugene's
efficiency in this video I want to focus
on how you set up your depth and test
set so the depth set is also called the
development set or sometimes called the
holdout cross validation set and
workflow in machine learning is that you
try all of ideas train up different
models on the training set and then use
the depth set to evaluate the different
ideas and pick one and keep iterating to
improve dead-set performance until
finally you have one classifier you
happy with that you then evaluate on
your test set now let's say by way of
example that you're building a
classifier and you are operating in
these regions in the US UK or the
European countries of America India
China of Asian countries in Australia so
how do you set up your deaf set or and
your test set well one way you could do
so is to pick four of these regions I'm
gonna use bespoke but it could be for
randomly chosen regions and say that
data from these four regions will go
into the deaf set and the other four
regions I'm going to use these four
complete randomly children for as well
that those who go into the test set it
turns out this is a very bad idea
because in this example your depth and
test sets come from different
distributions
I wouldn't instead recommend that you
find a way to make your depth and test
sets come from the same distribution so
here's what I mean one picture to keep
in mind is that I think setting up your
just yet plus your single real number
evaluation metric that's like placing a
target and telling your team where you
think of the Bulls are you want to aim
at because what happen once you've
established a depth set in metric is
that the team can iterate very quickly
how different ideas run experiments and
very quickly use the DEF set and the
to evaluate classifiers and try to pick
the best one so machine learning teams
are often very good at your shooting
different areas of the target and
iterating to get closer and closer to
hitting the bull's eye so doing well on
your metric on your death set and the
problem with how we've set up the dev
and test avenues out on the left is that
your team might spend months innovating
to do well on the death set or need to
realize that when you finally go to
testing on testbed that data from these
four countries or these four regions at
the bottom might be very different than
the regions in the dead sets so you
might have an office of cards and
realize that all the months of work you
spend optimizing to the death set it's
not giving you good performance on the
test set so having depth and test sets
from different distributions it's like
sending the target having a chance than
one's trying in close and closes
bullseye or need to realize often months
of work that you say oh wait to test it
I'm going to route the target over here
and the T might say well why'd you make
us spend months optimizing for a
difference bullseye when suddenly you
can move the bullseye to a different
location somewhere else so to avoid this
what I recommend instead is that you
take all this data preventing the
shuffle data into the depth and template
so that both the dev and test sets have
data from all eight regions and that the
data set really come from the same
distribution which is the distribution
of all the relays are mixed together
here's another example this is a
actually true story or some details
changed so I know machine learning teams
actually spent several months optimizing
on a death set which was comprised of
loan approvals for medium income zip
codes so the specific machine learning
problem was given in protects about a
loan application can you predict Y which
is whether or not they'll be paying
alone so this helps you decide whether
or not to approve a loan and so the DEF
sets came from loan applications they
came from medium income zip codes
Zucco's is what we call postal codes in
the United States but I've been working
on this for a few months the team then
suddenly decided to test this on data
from low-income zip codes or low-income
postal codes and of course the district
ocean of data for medium income and
lower-income zip codes is very different
than the cost failure then they spend so
much time optimizing in the former case
just didn't work well at all on the
latter case and so this took our team
actually wasted about three months of
time and had to go back and really do a
lot of work and what happened here what
the team spent three months aiming for
one target and then after three months
the manager asked oh how are you doing
on setting this other target is in a
totally different location and it just
was a very frustrating experience for
the team so what I recommend for
celebrate death set and test set is
choose a definite test set to reflect
data you expect to get in the future and
consider important to do well on and in
particular the death set and the test
set here should come from the same
distribution so whatever type of data
you expect to get in the future and want
to do well on try to get data that looks
like that and whatever that data is put
it into both your death set and your
test set because that way you're putting
the target where you actually want to
hit and you having the team iterate very
efficiently to hitting that same target
hopefully the same target well you
notice we haven't talked yet about how
to set up a training set we'll talk
about the training sets in a later video
but the important takeaway from this
video is that setting up the dev set as
well as the evaluation metric is really
defining what targets you want to aim at
and hopefully by setting the death set
and the test set to the same
distribution you're really aiming at
whatever target you hope your machine
learning team will hit the way you
choose your training set will affect how
long you can actually hit that target
but we can talk about that separately in
a later video so I know some machine
learning teams that could literally have
saved themselves months of work they
follow the guidelines in this video so
how these guidelines will help you to
mix it turns out that the size of the
dev a test says how to choose the size
of them is also changing a few Gurney
let's talk about that in the next video